der schwarzwald ist deutschlands
höchstes mittelgebirge er liegt im
südwesten des landes im bundesland baden
württemberg im kurort oberwolfach ist
das hotel und restaurant hirschen ein
beliebtes ziel für touristen auf der
speisekarte stehen fast nur regionale
spezialitäten eberhard junghans führt
den familienbetrieb bereits in der
vierten generation gemeinsam mit seiner
frau renate gasthof besteht schon seit
wir hatten vorher vor wenigen jahren in
400 jähriges jubiläum groß gefeiert
und das wo wir besonders wert darauf
legen ihrem restaurant ist einfach einen
sehr guten service zu bieten und sehr
gute zutaten zu verwenden in unserer
küche seine produkte bezieht eberhard
junghans aus der umgebung so auch die
kirchen die wichtigste zutat für das
heutige euromax rezept die schwarzwälder
kirschen tochter
der schwarzwälder kirsch sehr beliebt
die beliebte frucht überhaupt es gibt in
unserer region lässt sich gut verkaufen
zurück in der küche
eberhard jung hand hat alles vorbereitet
für eine tolle schwarzwälder kirschtorte
benötigen wir eier mehl zucker natürlich
die kirche divi reinlegen etwas
quarantäne und das wunderbare
kirschwasser das rezept stammt von
seinem vater
zunächst müssen die eier für den teig
getrennt werden nachdem das eiweiß in
einer maschine steif geschlagen wurde
wird es mit dem eigelb und dem zucker
verrührt
dann mehl und stärke dazu gehen
und zum schluss den kakao unter die
masse heben
den fertigen teig bei 160 grad celsius
20 minuten lang backen
währenddessen relativen kirschwasser
erhitzen und den fertigen tortenboden
dreimal teilen ein bisschen marinieren
mit kirschwasser dann die torte mit
eingelegten sauerkirschen belegen mit
dem kirschwasser zusammen in die saane
gerührt
die sahne gelatine mischung kommt als
oberste schicht auf die kirschen den
letzten top boden drauf und das ganze
mit sahne umgangen und garnieren
schokoladen späne sorgen für die
typische verkleidung der kalorienreichen
spezialität gemeinsam mit einzelnen
kirchen damit die torte auch bei
sommerlichen temperaturen schön frisch
bleibt sollte sie sofort in den
kühlschrank
im prinzip ist eine schwarzwälder
kirschtorte der schnellste kuchen der
welt würde ich sagen
man muss nur den kniff etwashausen haben
das problem ist eigentlich das
kirschwasser mit der shell und jene auf
den richtigen punkt in die saane zu
bekommen damit die sahne nicht gerinnt
so unsere ausgemachte schwarzwälder
kirschtorte ich wünsche ihnen einen
guten appetit
gegessen wird sie als dessert oder zum
nachmittagskaffee die schwarzwälder
kirschtorte ein rezept mit tradition